Cyprien : Ils sont arrivés ! On va ouvrir ça tout de suite !
C'est donc le triple vinyle de la première saison de l'épopée temporelle,
avec une illustration magnifique de Ben Fiquet.
Je suis trop heureux d'avoir un coffret physique avec un triple Vinyle Collector, il y a très très peu de pièces.
Pour vous le procurer bien évidemment il suffit d'aller sur narmol.fr
Chaque exemplaire est dédicacé.
Vous allez me dire : "Oui, mais Cyprien, j'ai pas de lecteur Vinyle !"
Mais ne vous inquiétez pas ! Il y a un code de téléchargement pour télécharger la version
numérique de l'épopée temporelle pour écouter absolument partout.
Ils vous attendent ça sera au pied du sapin peut-être je sais pas.
Je suis super content.
Le point culminant de l'épopée temporelle ça a été la diffusion du dernier épisode
dans une salle de cinéma à Paris. C'était un moment pour réunir tous les comédiens, les fans, toute l'équipe technique au montage-son,
mix-son, enregistrement, composition des musiques.
Je vous présente Navo, auteur sur l'Epopée Temporelle
ainsi que François Descraques et tout au bout nous avons Yacine, auteur et Hitler, il fait les deux dictateur/auteur
Yacine : "Il fallait crier tellement fort
et j'étais rouge et je hurlais
et c'est : "Tu pourrais être un peu plus vénère s'il te plaît ?"
Brigitte : "On s'en rendait pas compte nous quand on était dans les studios qu'il y avait tout ce monde là qui nous écoutait
et qui grandissait avec nous
et d'un seul coup il y a Internet qui arrive, on vous voit, et c'est génial quoi ! C'est super ! Merci d'être là pour Cyprien, et merci Cyprien"
Cyprien : C'est libérateur en fait de faire une série audio. Ca a été un travail super intéressant. Toute la série est maintenant sur sur ma chaîne YouTube
donc je vous invite à l'écouter si c'est pas déjà fait voilà. Ca parle de voyage dans le temps des personnages un petit peu
débiles, de toutes les formes de toutes les tailles
qui vont traverser les époques pour une quête qui est : retrouver l'inventeur de la machine à voyager dans le temps qui a disparu.
Dr. Simon : "Iris ? qu'est-ce que tu fais là ?" "Quoi ? Les balises retour ?"
Cyprien : Quand j'ai eu l'idée de faire cette série je me suis dit faudrait que je le fasse avec des comédiens professionnels
des comédiens de doublage et du coup j'ai rencontré plein de comédiens et c'était exactement ceux que je voulais qui ont
participé dont je suis content il n'y a pas eu de compromis aucun.
Quand je te propose de faire un rôle d'enfant nazi, tu dis oui toi ?
Brigitte : Bah oui ! Moi je dis oui !
Véronique : Je vais dédicacer ça à toutes les nymphos.
Cyprien : Elle fait la mère et Cléopâtre donc que des femmes, voilà, qui aime la chair.
Mac : F = Constante*M*M'/d²
d étant la distance qui sépare deux objets de masse M et M' voilà.
- Cyprien : Ça c'est la base ça visiblement
(rires)
Mac : Et ça c'est juste la base
Sam : Le challenge c'était de trouver des voix qui ont la force, qui ont l'émotion
et qui peuvent illustrer parfaitement des personnages légendaires juste avec des voix donc du coup c'est des voix qui ont du charisme.
Imhotep : Mais je viens de l'inventer ! Merde, laissez moi au moins terminer mes énigmes !
La Buse : "Ah ! Intéressant ! Pour 5 000 pièces, je tue qui vous voulez !"
Iris : "Oh merde ! Qu'est-ce qu'on va faire ?"
"Peut-être l'avez-vous..."
Dorothée : Iris elle est hyper sympa
elle a peur de rien elle est juste un petit peu froide dans ses rapports amoureux avec Thomas mais
les aventures qu'ils vont vivre vont peut-être changer tout ça.
Elliot : "Bonjour cher humain" "Désolé mais tu ne me sers à rien"
Martial : Mon personnage est assez sympa,
c'est vrai que j'aurais eu des fois envie d'en faire beaucoup plus mais c'est pas dans son caractère
puisqu'il reste assez sobre dans l'ensemble.
Cyprien : Il est très sobre, très simple, mais il offre l'aventure à un loser.
Ils ont incarné des personnages
incroyables, ça m'a fait super plaisir, c'était très intimidant de jouer face à eux d'ailleurs. Tout le monde a été super.
Pour une série audio, moi je m'estime vraiment comblé
Iris : "Putain de nazis de merde !"
Thomas : "Ah ouais, je comprends mieux pourquoi tu t'étais pas très emballé par cette époque...
...parce que c'est la guerre !"
Elliot : "Fuyons la zone de combat !"
Cyprien : Je voulais collaborer aussi avec des illustrateurs
c'est à dire avoir cette base de série audio pour que des gens puissent la mettre en image. Par contre, c'était important pour moi qu'il y ait pas
un seul illustrateur, je voulais que tous les dessins et les styles soient parsemés. Comme ça, l'auditeur il se dit :
"Euh .. Eh ben moi je préfère cette version là" ou alors "Tiens cette version là est pas mal"
L'audio permet de faire imaginer ce qu'on veut.
Voilà quoi la saison 1 est terminée elle existe maintenant en Vinyle,
on peut penser à la suite quoi.
J'ai vécu plein de choses c'était formidable
et merci d'avoir partagé ça avec moi en l'écoutant et en donnant vos retours, et moi je vous dis à très vite sur ma chaîne YouTube.
(Générique de l'Épopée Temporelle...
(Rembobinage)
Je suis DJ aussi
... Générique de l'Épopée Temporelle)